[Musique]
ce que vous croyez aux extraterrestres
l'abbé la main ceux qui croient je vous
félicite parce que moi j'y crois pas du
tout et pourtant s'il ya des 15-30 ans
dans la sage désolé je vois pas du tout
la salle il ya sûrement des 15-30 ans
dans la salle oui voilà est-ce que vous
voulez bien vous lever les 15 30 ans
allez-y devez vous allez bravo au
fantastique et bien tous ceux qui ne
croient pas aux extraterrestres s'il
vous plaît regardez les vous en avez en
face de vous merci en fait voilà
exactement ce dont nous allons parler de
ces jeunes qui sont ce qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui des aliens gêne
bien sûr vous allez me dire ce sont nos
enfants que ce que nous raconte
extraterrestre non juste nos enfants aux
enfants est ce que vous croyez vraiment
que ce ne sont pas les enfants de
quelqu'un d'autre ou non je ne parlais
pas de ça ou plus exactement de quelque
chose d'autre
et en l'occurrence de l'évolution en
réalité ces enfants ce sont les enfants
de darwin darwin ça vous parle
pourquoi ce sont les enfants de darwin
c'est ce que je vais essayer de vous
expliquer au cours de ce toc c'est parti
les enfants de darwin vous avez
aujourd'hui beaucoup de sociétés qui
s'intéressent à ce qu'on appelle les
millennials ce les millennials ce sont
sept générations nées peu ou prou au
milieu des années 80 voire 90 et on
s'est dit ou à la comportement différent
il faut essayer de comprendre un petit
peu mieux comment il fonctionne et donc
vous avez des marketeurs vous avez tous
ces gens qui ont l'habitude d'étudier
les différents segments de population
qui cherche à connaître leurs centres
d'intérêt leur mode de communication
leur consommation
en réalité mon travail a consisté en
tant que maire en tant qu'enseignante en
tant que chercheurs mais aussi en tant
qu'employeur essayer de les comprendre
mais si les comprendre différemment qui
sont ils réellement ces aliens gêne ses
enfants darwin en fait nous pouvons nous
rendre compte que nous les voyons nous
les les quinquas a trait à travers le
regard que nous portons sur eux
en tant que parents et ce regard et bien
vous le voyez c'est d'abord un regard
sur leur ennui leur désespérante ennuis
essayer de leur proposer n'importe quel
type d'activité
vous recevez un enthousiasme assez
modérée essayer leur proposer des livres
que vous considérez extrêmement
intelligents ils vont rester un certain
temps sur leur chever essayer de leur
faire partager une culture que vous
pensez être une culture fondamentale
pour eux et vous regarde à cannes un
petit peu condescendant disant que d'une
culture du passé somme toute
fâché alors évidemment la complexité
c'est que il joue oui je sais c'est très
très perturbant pour vous il joue
normalement notre génération nous avons
arrêté de jouer quand nous avons atteint
une dizaine d'années on a commencé à
nous expliquer que ça y est on devenait
cran et que le jeu c'est fait pour les
tout petits pas pour l'écran et donc
progressivement nous avons abandonné je
veux ils ont 15 ans 20 ans 25 ans 30 ans
35 ans et continue encore à jouer
désespérément alors évidemment c'est
s'est fâché s'est fâché parce que
pendant qu'ils jouent ils ne sortent pas
il ne sert pas elle ne rencontre pas des
autres vous voyez vous connaissez tous
je pas besoin est néanmoins néanmoins
ses enfants sont de plus en plus
différent de ce que vous étiez et ce
n'est pas qu'un effet de génération
nous avons tendance à penser que oui et
nous aussi nous avons été jeunes ou
alors oui mai 68
voilà non non ils sont en train
d'exprimer une transition massive du
monde que nous avons connus qui est ce
monde bien ordonnée bien réglé et que
nos parents nos grands parents nous ont
légué et au sein duquel finalement nous
sommes extrêmement confortable les
choses sont en ordre bien régler les
choses sont claires sont un petit peu
machiste
disons que l'homme il ya une certaine
prévalence elles sont très logique
rationnelle compétitive aussi l problème
c'est que pour eux c'est l'hédonisme qui
compte se trouver le bonheur savoir des
émotions c'est être dans l'expérience
s'est finalement laissé s'exprimer ses
valeurs féminines même lorsqu'en et ana
c'est possible aussi
en réalité ces enfants sont
fondamentalement différentes non ils
sont différents bien au-delà de ce que
vous même pouvez voir leurs processus
cognitifs a été singulièrement altéré
changé par leur apprentissage des
nouvelles technologies le fait qu avant
même de savoir lire écrire et compter
il est accéder à un autre mode
d'acquisition des connaissances à
changer leur système cognitif
le nôtre est basée sur ce qu'on appelle
une approche séquentiel ça va commencer
un livre en haut vous allez pour nous de
gauche à droite vous descendez vous
revenez vous passez suivre lorsqu'il
s'agit de d'équations fait la même chose
on découpe et on résout fur et à mesure
pour eux ce système leur devient de plus
en plus étranger dans la tête ils sont
ce qu'on appelle un plex un plex d'un
espèce d espace mental dans lequel il se
promène par association d'idées par
envie par impulsion bien loin de nos
logiques bien loin de notre rationalité
et du coup nous avons beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de mal à dialoguer avec
beaucoup de mal à comprendre où ils
veulent aller exactement beaucoup de mal
à ne pas nous insurger contre leur
manière de se promener dans un monde
mental qui nous devient lui aussi
totalement étranger
alors évidemment ça nous donne des
choses comme par exemple la mémoire la
mémoire est en train de changer chez nos
enfants on vient bien aujourd'hui il
teste qui sont faits nous montre que la
mémoire que vous pouvez acquérir à
l'école est une mémoire relativement
superficielles inversement dès qu'ils se
mettent à pratiquer les réseaux sociaux
et bien cette mémoire explose elle prend
de nouvelles dimensions et pourtant vous
leur avez tous recommandé fortement de
se promener le moins possible dans les
réseaux sociaux le téléphone combien de
fois ne leur avait pas dit que
évidemment les émissions du téléphone
allait leur griller le cerveau qu' il
allait devenir totalement sourd à force
d'écouter les écouteurs dans les
oreilles et que cet objet qu'il ne
quitte plus haut point d'être finalement
le véritable prolongement temps de leur
cerveau que de leurs mains vous savez
qu'ils ont des pousses qui deviennent
désormais extrêmement curieux et bien
tout ça en réalité construit leur
nouvelle forme d'intelligence une forme
d'intelligence
vous le voyez qui nous échappe un petit
peu ne serait ce que sur le plan du fab
éthique mais qui les emmènent surtout à
une autre manière de penser une manière
de coups de bons c'est totalement
décomplexés ils sont parfaitement prêts
à vous soutenir des raisonnements dont
la logique vous échappe un peu mais dont
ils sont absolument persuadé leur
technique c'est l'intuition aller
directement un fait et lorsque vous leur
demander de nous expliquer se fait de
manière rationnelle ne comprennent
vraiment pas pourquoi ils ont besoin de
s'encombrer demandé aux enseignants et
vous verrez qu'ils sont furieusement
confrontés à ce type de problématique
les employeurs aussi essayé de demander
à un employeur comment il se comporte
avec ses alliés le gêne vous allez voir
que c'est compliqué en termes de
management
c'est encore pire vraiment de bonne
heure le matin il loupe la plupart des
réunions ils oublient allègrement une
partie de leurs tâches
voir ils ont des lecques d'autres à des
collègues parce que il y à quelques pas
un macho
ou un séjour à l'étranger qui n'ont pas
envie de rater c'est à dire compliqué à
chair et en même temps ce que nous
voyons c'est que ils forment un embryon
un nouvel embryon qui nous conduit à ce
qu'on appelle un humain 2.0
l'humain 2.0 considérant que nous
serions l'humain 1.0 et bien c'est celui
qui va faire un bond en avant aussi
grand que le bond en avant que nous
avons fait lorsque nous avons décidé de
nous sédentarisés l époque nous étions
des chasseurs cueilleurs nous étions des
nomades éleveurs et puis un beau matin
sur un assez long laps de temps
un beau matin eh bien nous avons
construit des villes nous avons produit
nous avons échangé et nous avons
développée la civilisation que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui c'est exactement
ce qu'ils sont en train de faire bien
sûr ça nous est difficile de l'accepter
mais si vous regardez un petit peu ce
qu'ils font aujourd'hui bien vous voyez
que déjà ils ont posé des fondamentaux
qui sont extrêmement intéressants
nous avons toujours vécu toute notre
civilisation est fondée sur le fait de
fabriquer des objets comme on
s'approprie ensuite eh bien ils ont déjà
passé cette étape il ne cherche plus à
s'approprier tout ce qu'ils veulent
c'est l'accès
l'accès au mode de déplacement l'accès à
la santé l'éducation éventuellement
juste l'accès plus la propriété
bien sûr on insiste sur le fait que ce
soit des natifs digitaux oui bien sûr
mais ce n'est pas seulement ça c'est
qu'aujourd'hui ils ont envie de
collaborer par évidemment dans le monde
ultra compétitifs que nous avons
développées c'est compliqué d'avoir des
gens qui essayent de collaborer il se
met à vous parlais à peine une année
chaque innovation ouverte open data
données ouvertes normalement non de les
négocier ces données il essaye de donner
gratuitement un savoir qu'ils ont acquis
alors que pour nous c'est une source de
propriété intellectuelle c'est une
source de valorisation
donc ça ne la parle déjà plus en réalité
cet alien generation est déjà prête et
déjà prête pour un nouveau monde
or ce nouveau monde n'est pas vraiment
celui que nous leur proposons celui que
nous leur proposons c'est un monde dans
lequel les ressources naturelles sont
considérablement dévastés dans lequel le
changement climatique va
considérablement altéré les choses
encore à l'avenir et dans lequel
finalement on leur dit écoutez comme on
l entend à l'avenir votre compétiteurs
principal ce sera le grand beau et donc
nous on vous réserve des emplois qui ne
sont pas extrêmement extrêmement
folichon attirant vous allez des
programmeurs décodeur vous allez
maintenir des robots est ce que nous
leur vendons du rêve bien sûr que non
bien sûr que non alors certains d'entre
eux déjà ont décidé de refuser cela et
pour ça eh bien ils refusent l'éducation
il faut refuser formation il refuse le
travail
il s'isole du monde 4 millions en europe
1 million japon et ont certainement pas
compter tous les pays alors comment
faire de ces jeunes ils veulent sauter
du bocal il va essayer d'inventer un
nouveau monde mais nous quel futur le
réservant dans un futur qui est celui
qu'on leur prépare à l'instar d'une
autre avec exactement ce qu'on a demandé
à vos parents et à vous-même
on tient absolument pas compte de leur
compétence du fait qu'ils sont cette
qualité de zapper mais aussi cette
qualité de synthèse que il refuse la
pénibilité mais qu'ils ont une
créativité souvent extrêmement
intéressante
en réalité ce que nous cherchons c'est
juste à nier cette identité
il n'existe pas ils vont mûrir ils vont
vieillir et vont revenir dans le moule
et voit comme nous et ils vont continuer
de pérenniser ce monde que nous
connaissons et peut-être pas peut-être
qu'en réalité ce qu'ils voudront s'est
inventé ce monde que déjà avec leur
start up déjà avec leur nomadisme
différents différents métiers différents
jobs différentes études différents pays
que déjà ils sont en train d'inventer et
nous et nous dans tout ça et nous
comment comment réussissons nous a à les
aimer dans ce monde là comment
réussissons nous à les aider est ce que
finalement le noeud du problème
comme le précédent speaker le disais ce
n'est pas là la technologie c'est nous
là ce ne sont pas nos enfants le
problème c'est nous c'est la manière
dont les dons dont les accueillons la
manière dont nous les aidons et si
finalement la seule preuve d'amour qui
soit vraiment c'était simplement de le
faire confiance merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]